[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue sur 9 7 4 tv dans
cet épisode on nous vous emmenons à la
découverte de la forêt du maïdo
[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui nous allons effectuer
la deuxième partie du vélo run festival
avec grégory maillot son organisateur
en effet nous allons partir à la
découverte de la deuxième boucle qui
traverse une belle forêt de tamarins et
qui réservait un public confirmé on
profitera de cette boucle pour parler
des hommes qui entretiennent au
quotidien cet espace je veux parler des
agents de l'office national des forêts
je vous présenterai également dominique
valin qui nous parlera de son métier
entre tradition et modernité
celui de bardottier c'est parti
[Musique]
la forêt du maïdo est connue sous le nom
de forêt des hauts sous le vent
c'est le site naturel le plus visité sur
l'île après le pas de bellecombe et ce
sont les agents de l'unef qui tout au
long de l'année travaille à
l'aménagement de cet espace en 2016
l'office national des forêts fêter ses
50 ans d'implantation sur le territoire
ces agents sont les gardiens et les
protecteurs de nos forêts il les
entretiennent et les aménag afin que le
plus grand nombre de personnes puissent
profiter de ses paysages
il préserve également la biodiversité de
nos sites d'exception désormais inscrit
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
dès que votre regard se porte sur un
élément on peut imaginer qu'un ouvrier
forestier ou un agent de lohan est
intervenue à ce moment-là ce soit sur
les tables le mandat que du petit trou
du public pour les pique-niques du
week-end que les réunionnais affectionne
particulièrement sur les sentiers
touristiques pour entretenir ses
sentiers pour travailler à
l'amélioration de la qualité de ses
sentiers aussi sur la lutte contre les
espèces exotiques envahissantes sur des
replantations de la sylviculture avec le
tamarin et la préservation de ces
espèces endémiques
mais aussi contre la lutte contre les
incendies de feux de forêt
malheureusement bien connu sur le sur la
forêt des hauts sous le vent avec mise
en place d'infrastructures adaptées de
piste de citernes et là c'est un gros
défi pour les années à venir justement
que nous devons réaliser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme tu peux le voir on a fini avec la
sélection exigeante des lave on est
maintenant sur un terrain beaucoup plus
souple qui traverse le pare-feu 2800 au
maïdo et là on se rapproche de l'arrivée
d'accord combien de kilomètres encore
pour finir est moins 10 km avec eux même
si on y va
allez on y va dans la famille va là on
travaille le bois dominique lui a choisi
d'être bardottier un savoir faire qu'il
perpétue dans cette forêt rencontre
[Musique]
il est l'un des derniers menuisier à
couper le bois de cette façon dominique
valin et bardottier et c'est au coeur de
cette forêt du maïdo qu'il travaille le
tamarin des hauts ce savoir faire
traditionnels il a appris par son oncle
le geste est précis
le bardo doit faire en moyenne 15 mm
d'épaisseur chaque arbre dans cette
forêt est unique dans sa courbe et
dominique suit le fil du bois pour créer
chacune de ses pièces
mais après quand c'est des bois comme ça
les su appuyer les paras vert après un
cyclone ou la tête et cassé l'iphone ou
savoir carrément au relenza
les v
si les épaules pour autant brodziak a
pris la main dans l'atelier et comme
c'est un travail il faut
tout le temps où les très vigilant parce
que le petit h il écoute très bien si
vous fait pas attention et du coup de
blanc mais touche du bois d'ailleurs
c'est médical en voilà et c'est un
travail tous les jours il faut faire le
même geste et les très difficile c'est
un travail physique il faut connaît
reconnaît le tir il faut connaître votre
matériel
il faut webroot métier et il faut pas
oublier aussi
[Musique]
l'émission se termine merci à grégory de
nous avoir fait découvrir ses beaux
sentiers du maïdo merci à toi michael je
vous donne rendez vous le dimanche 10
avril à trois bassins pour une belle
journée au grand air en famille entre
amis
super merci à toute l'équipe merci à
emmanuel alexandre pour les prises de
vue
vous pourrez retrouver ce programme sur
le facebook de 9 7 4 tv à bientôt
[Musique]